[Musik]
die
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sallys
enthalte gibt's eine sackgasse motiv
torte und zwar haben wir was ist das ein
rentier und zwar nicht irgendeinen
rentier genau warum rudolf gemacht denn
rudolph hat eine perfekt und die motiv
dort ist wirklich super einfach zu
machen und gefällt vor allem kind dann
ganz gut und dem buch hat auch das ist
gleich was ich am besten zu mir alle vor
allem finde ich schön
die haben wir jetzt gleich noch mal dran
und sie war mutter gibt es gleich vor
allem geld fällt der sanierer
wahrscheinlich ganz gut dass sie später
das gemeint was sowieso ein schoko lolly
aufessen kann oder ich glaube steckten
dann salzburgerin jedenfalls zeigen wir
euch jetzt mal zuerst wie man den teig
herstellen und rudolf ist wirklich ganz
einfach zu machen
für den teig brauch ich sechs eier 300
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz 300 milliliter
buttermilch und 250 milliliter öl 450
gramm je 40 gramm kakaopulver ein
päckchen backpulver und einen teelöffel
zimt und 200 gramm haselnüsse für den
teig gebe ich jetzt die eier gemeinsam
mit zucker vanillezucker und weil in der
rührschüssel und verrührt sieht darin
etwa vier bis fünf minuten
[Musik]
die zwei flüssigkeiten bei niedriger
stufe mit rein
und jetzt kommen noch die trockenen
zutaten mit dazu
[Musik]
jetzt hast du noch die haare so mit dazu
geben und die haben wir bereits fein
gemahlen in macbeth drive blender und
die zutaten mir jetzt noch kurz
eingerührt
[Musik]
und den teig fühle ich jetzt in zwei
vorbereitete bettringen mit 20
zentimetern durchmesser falls ihr nur
ein und habt empfehle ich euch den teig
zu halbieren als erstes zu machen und
dann die andere hälfte
[Musik]
und die zeigen werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 40 bis 45 minuten
gebacken
[Musik]
die tage sind jetzt abgekühlt und ich
habe auch bereits eine portion sagt
peter karrasch gemacht und werde
tortenböden ersten hier von der folie
ablösen
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich die tortenböden mit
einer trotten säge jeweils ein bis
zweimal durchschneiden aber ich mach
zwei mal und habe ich schönere trocken
würden
[Musik]
die tortenböden bestreite ich jetzt
jeweils mit einer ganz dünnen schicht
sagt peter karrasch und setzte so
zusammen und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
sie an der stelle auch gerne mit etwas
rum oder liter trinken oder auch einen
sack nehmen oder zum beispiel auch ein
bisschen adeln
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich den letzten decke noch
drauf den einen klassisch übrig den kann
also verlassen
und jetzt werde die torte einmal
komplett mit der kamera ein streit
[Musik]
so kann ich die torte jetzt erst mal
eine halbe stunde durch kühlen weil die
kanalstadt nochmal mit dem schneebesen
durchrühren und dann geht's gleich
weiter
[Musik]
die kanal schreibe ich jetzt noch mal
mit kitchenette glatt gerührt also wie
gesagt entweder nehmen dir dann ein
handrührgerät oder im schneebesen zum
beispiel dem schneebesen geht's wirklich
ein bisschen schwer weil es hat auch
eine ziemlich feste creme ist
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die creme in einem
spritzbeutel hab mir vorne eine stern
thüle mix 10 mm durchmesser und kann
jetzt die komplette torte mit den töpfen
gespritzt und das ist dann sozusagen das
feld von rudolf da fangt ihr unten an
[Musik]
zwei doch zwei noch das reicht noch das
war maßarbeit
jetzt stelle ich die torte kurz kühl und
macht das rentier gemein
jetzt bereite ich hier die dekoration
für rudolf form und zwar habe ich 200
gramm peter kuvertüre bereits
geschmolzen
also ich hab sie temperiert erst zwei
drittel der kuvertüre über dem warmen
wasserbad erwärmt dann vom wasserbad
heruntergenommen und das restliche
drittel eingerührt und so habe ich jetzt
die temperatur von 28 29 grad und die
kuvertüre lässt sich so am besten weiter
verarbeiten
[Musik]
natürlich in einem spritzbeutel drin
können zum beispiel auch einen
gefrierbeutel ganz gut nehmen den dann
verschließen
jetzt habe ich hier ein backpapier ich
würde jetzt am liebsten de bug folie
nehmen aber darauf steht ist einfach ein
bisschen besser und appliziert bei
schlick spieße und die habe ich schon
ein bisschen gekürzt und die werde ich
später in die torte reinstecken zu das
geweih einfach auch gut stehen kann
jetzt sei es hier eine spitze ab und
werde jetzt das 2 um diese stäbchen
herum machen das heißt und ein bisschen
platz lassen das kommt die torte jetzt
hier erstmal den stamm dann nach oben
hin bissen runter
und dann hier unten noch
[Musik]
und falls jetzt die form nicht ganz so
schön ist wie ihr sie wollte nimmt ihr
nochmal ein schaschlik spies und können
so ein bisschen in form ziehen
[Musik]
dass gewalt sich jetzt auch einen torten
retter und stellt einfach kurz in den
kühlschrank dann kann das innerhalb von
fünf bis zehn minuten fest werden dann
tricks und bespritzt einfach noch die
andere seite damit man das schaschlik
spießchen da nicht sieht jetzt habe ich
hier noch modelle schokolade in rot weiß
und schwarz rot verwende ich natürlich
für gut als roter nase
das ist auch ganz einfach da müsst ihr
nur eine kugel formen
da ist sicher und jetzt nehme ich noch
weiß und formen die augen und zwar am
besten der kugel formen die dann leicht
oral und dann so ein bisschen flach
drücken
[Musik]
ein bisschen schwarz und bei mir darf
rudolf ein bisschen spielen sie dann
immer sie es aus und damit die zieht
kugel draufgesetzt und dann flach
gedrückt
[Musik]
und zum schluss kommen jetzt nur noch
die zwei lichtpunkte in die augen
[Musik]
jetzt können wir die torte fertigstellen
samira ok als wärme die nase gerieben
die darfst du ankleben warte dann klebe
ich zuerst die augen an ok und zwar
würde ich die arge hier vorne ankleben
einfach rein drücken
[Musik]
und jetzt noch das 4 1
und zwar hier ist die mitte dann kommt
es gerade einmal hier und jetzt mit ganz
ganz vorsichtig ok zusammen
so gefällt ihr so ok das darfst du
später ist ein kind so jetzt kann
angeschnitten werden samira musste
leider jetzt schon zum ballett deswegen
darf jetzt der partie probieren
ich freue mich ja ich hoffe ich dass man
wieder probieren
ich glaube das leiden dich lieb ich
lieb' schokoladenkuchen
und das ist nicht nur schokolade sondern
haselnuss kavala
[Musik]
jetzt
schaut euch jetzt ein megamäßig großes
stück also du musst nicht alleine auf
messen
aber du kannst natürlich bitter
[Musik]
so richtig lecker aus saftig ich probier
mal super lecker schokolade merkt man
die hassel würdest du weiter im film ja
dein bruder bedeutet ja wahrscheinlich
mein bruder liebt schokoladenkuchen
eigentlich ist das nur schokoladenkuchen
und ich glaube ich muss ihm natürlich
auch ein stückchen vorbeibringen falls
sie jetzt auch lust auf diese torte
bekommen habt dann schaut doch mal auf
meinem blog vorbei auf cds - blog.de
vielleicht habt ihr noch keine torte für
weihnachten und das war so eine
lastminute idee die man einfach super
schnell machen kann und vor allem die
superoffice aussieht und falls ihr es
hier nach macht dann könnt ihr gerne ein
foto auf facebook app instagram zb
teilen und ich schaue mir das foto ganz
gerne an und jetzt wünschen wir euch
allen ganz schöne weihnachten und ganz
viele ruhige und schöne tage mit der
familie und werden uns dann beim
nächsten mal bis dann und ich würde
sagen zur feier des tages haben wir
jetzt alle rein und alle dürfen
probieren darf sie nachts muss nämlich
auch das schweizer fernsehen und dazu
versucht bietet jetzt auch probieren
[Musik]